if we can go back to the incredible work
with Abraham Accords and U Israel in the
Middle East first the big question about
peace why is it so difficult to achieve
peace in this part of the world between
Israel and Palestine and between Israel
and the other countries in the Middle
East or any sort of peace likee
agreements if I had to give you the most
simple answer I would say that it's
structural and if you go back to the in
structure of different leaders this
whole peace process between Israel and
and the
Palestinians um and again I've gotten
criticized for saying this but it's what
I believe so I'm going to say it is that
the incentive structure was all wrong
and when I went before the United
Nations security Council to discuss the
peace plan that I proposed which again
was more of an operational plan and it
was a pragmatic plan it was over 180
pages in detail in Pol in politics
people don't like putting forward detail
because it just gives a lot of places
for you to get critic criticized on
nobody actually criticized the detail of
my plan they just
criticized the fact that it was coming
from us and didn't want to debate the
merits of the operational pieces of it
so I created a slide where I showed from
the Oslo Accords till the day I was
there all the different piece
discussions I put a dove in the slide
for those and then I put a tank for
every time there was a war there was
always skirmishes between Hamas and and
Hezbollah and and the Palestinians and
then I showed two lines and they both
went from the bottom of the page all the
way up like this one of the lines was
Israeli settlements so every time uh a
negotiation failed Israel was able to
get more land and every and then the
other one was money to the Palestinians
and I said every time a negotiation
failed the Palestinians would get more
money the problem with that money though
was that it wasn't going to the people
you know a lot some of it would make its
way down but most of it was going to the
politicians you had leadership of the
Palestinians who was basically I think
at that point in like the 16th year of a
four-year term so he wasn't
democratically elected and a lot of what
I tried to show was that there was no
rule of law there was no Judicial System
there were no property rights and there
was no opportunity or hope for the
people to live a better life and so all
of the uh envoys to date were basically
trained to go and do the same things and
I again I got massively criticized by
all the previous envoys for not doing it
the same way they did but I thought the
problem structurally just didn't make
sense and so I felt like the incentive
structure was all wrong and I took a
different approach and so what's what's
the different approach I started writing
down a document these are the you know
11 issues but there's really only three
issues that matter I said just tell me
what you think the compromise is that
you think the other side could live with
that you would accept and it was very
hard to get them talking about this oh
you have to go back to 1972 you have to
go back to 1982 you have to go back to
2001 you have to go to camp and I was
just like I don't need a headache and I
don't need a history lesson just just I
want a very simple thing here today in
2017 what's the outcome that you would
accept and I was dealing with their
their their negotiators their back
Channel secret negotiators their double
secret I was like this whole thing is
like it's a process created where nobody
wants to talk about uh the actual
solution so coming from the business
world I said okay let me just write down
a proposed solution that I think is fair
and let me have each side react like
don't tell me about theoretical things
like tell me I want to move the line
from here to here I want to change this
word so I tried to make it much more
tactical and what I realized was like
the Palestinians they'd worked so hard
to get the Arab world to stay with the
line of the Arab peace initiative and so
I went back and I read the air peace
initiative it was 10 lines and it didn't
have any detail so it was a concept and
so they liked that concept because it
allowed them to reject everything they
kept getting more money I mean BB
Netanyahu who runs uh one of the most
incredible EC economies in the world who
runs an incredible superpower uh
militarily for the size of of their
country he would fly to Washington to
meet us and he'd be taking a commercial
LOL plane MH a boss who runs a refugee
organization a refugee group right that
claims that they don't have a state that
gets billions of dollars in eight year
eight every year from the global
Community would fly in a $60 million
Boeing BBJ so the whole thing was just
very corrupt and off and I do think that
that's why it um I don't think people
were incentivized to solve it to be
honest what do you think an actual plan
on that part if you can just before we
talk
about uh Abraham Accords if there is a
peace plan that works between Israel and
Palestine what is it what do you think
it looks like you have to separate it
into two different issues and I think
that that's actually how we came to the
Abraham Accords is that you know I I I
was I tell the story in the book and it
was one of my like favorite experiences
during my time in diplomacy where where
I went to meet with Sultan kaboose who
was the Sultan of Oman and we fly out
there because he'd had a secret meeting
with BB and I thought maybe he was open
to uh normalizing with Israel so after
he meets with BB he calls me and says I
want you to come see me so I go over to
see him and I again I tell the story it
was a crazy you know night in all these
different areas but when I was talking
to him um he basically says to me I feel
badly for the Palestinian people that
they carry with them the burden of the
Muslim world
and that line just like stuck with me
and a couple days later I was thinking
about it and I said wait a
minute who elected the Palestinian
people to represent the Muslim World on
the aloa mosque and so the reason why I
felt like it had never been solved was
it was a riddle a that I believed was
designed to not be solved but B you were
conflating two separate issues you had
the issue between Israel and and the
Muslim World which really was the issue
of the alaka mosque and then you had
just a territorial dispute which
throughout history you have lots of
territorial disputes and they're usually
resolved in different ways so if you go
back to the Israeli Palestinian issue
there's just a couple components you
need to solve number one is territorial
contiguity right you need to figure out
where do you draw the lines and that's
something that you know you can talk
about what people were owed 70 years ago
but it's much more productive to say
this is what you can make work today
right and that's kind of what we did I
we literally spent months and months
drawing a map and we put something out
probably Chang a couple lines here and
there but by and large it was a very
pragmatic solution um that I think could
work and I think it could work for the
Safety and Security of Israel which was
number one um so first issue is drawing
a map second issue was security again
Israel um and again this is one issue we
were incredibly sympathetic with Israel
which is you can't expect a you know a
prime minister of Israel to make a deal
where he's going to make his people less
secure than before so we worked very
closely with them on a security
apparatus we laid something out that I
think would keep the whole area safer
and it would it would make sure Israel
was safe and also keep the Palestinian
yesu safe so you need security number
three was the religious sites and that
was one that was actually always made
much more complicated by people uh the
aloa mosque because you basically have
Haram Al Sharif which is a place where
the mosque was built in the seventh or
8th Century um but originally it was
where the the holy of holies were in the
beta mdash for the Jewish people so and
then you know compounding by the fact
that you have all the Christian holy
sites in Jerusalem it's a city that
should be bringing everyone together but
in fact has become a place where you
have you know Wars and and and and and
hatred and a lot of different conflicts
that have risen because of it but what I
said was instead of fighting over
concepts of sovereignty which is
interesting how I got to the notion that
this wasn't really the big issue I B
said just operationally why don't we
just make it simple let everyone come
and be able to worship as long as
they're being able to worship peacefully
so that's really the Contours of it and
what the Palestinians have done is
they've kind of deflected from a lot of
their own shortcomings and a lot of the
Arab leaders did that as well kind of in
the pre- Abraham mord Days by kind of
allowing this issue to be so prevalent
so one thing I'll say on the
Palestinians is that you know what we
tried to do by laying outed plan was we
said okay um what are the reasons why
the Palestinian people are not having
the lives that they deserve I'll give
you a couple things one is I studied the
economies of you know Jordan uh West
Bank Gaza Egypt Morocco uh this was you
know numbers from like 2019 but what was
interesting was the GDP per capita of
somebody living in the West Bank was
actually the same as Jordan and it was
actually more than somebody living in
Egypt and the debt to GDP that the
Palestinians had was like 30 40%
compared to Egypt which was at like 130%
and Jordan which was at 110% and Lebanon
which is at 200% and so you know you're
in a situation where a lot lot of this
stuff didn't make sense but if you draw
lines create institutions where
Palestinian people can now feel like
they have property rights and have
ownership over their place and let the
money flow past the leadership ranks uh
you know to the people let them have
jobs let them have opportunity and then
let all Muslims from throughout the
world have access to the mosque and
Israel making sure that they can control
the security which I think the
jordanians and a lot of others want
Israel to to have strong you know
security control there to prevent the
radicalists and the extremists from
coming
you could have peace there very easily
so there's a lot of things to say here
one is just to emphasize uh Alexa MK
says this this holy place and this is
something in our conversations and in my
own travels I've seen the importance of
sort of frictionless access to those
sites from the entirety of the Muslim
world and that's what Abraham of course
took big leaps on okay so we'll talk
about that a little bit more
uh but that's kind of a religious
component that's a a dignity in the
religious practice and Faith component
but then the other thing you mentioned
so
um uh simply which is you have money
flow past the leadership ranks how do
you have money flow past the leadership
ranks in uh in Palestine so uh make sure
that the money that's invested in
Palestine the West Bank gets to the
people so to date all of the aid that's
been given to the Palestinians has been
an entitlement it's not conditions based
it's always just we give the money and
there's no expectations it's very simple
you make the aid conditions based you
fight for transparency you do it through
institutions other than the PA or you
put reformers into the PA that will
allow it to go down that way PA being
the Palestinian Authority which is the
leadership it's not hard to do it just
takes people who actually want to do it
but I think the the the mindset of the
International Community has not been let
solve this problem it's like let's just
throw a little bit of money the money's
novacaine let's put a little Novacane on
the problem and let's not have to deal
with it but nobody's ever said oh let's
do an accounting of the2 billion we've
given them and see how many jobs it's
done and where it's gone that just
hasn't happened again it's it's it's an
incredibly corrupt organization unra you
think about the postor War II Dynamic
you had a lot of refugees my
grandparents were refugees post World
War II every other Refugee class has
been resettled and you only have one
permanent refugee organiz ation ever
created why was this done it was done to
perpetuate the conflict so that a lot of
Arab leaders could basically deflect
from a lot of their shortcomings at home
and so I think for Israel they view all
these things as existential they value
their safety they've been under attack
for a long time I do think having a deal
where we can say how do you know the
Jews and the Muslims Chris come together
I think King Abdullah from Jordan's been
an incredible custodian for the mosque I
think everyone in my travels recognized
that he's the right guy for that that
the the King of Jordan should be the
custodian of of the mosque um we should
have some kind of framework to make sure
everyone has access the more countries
that have diplomatic relations with
Israel the more Muslims and Arabs that
should be able to come and and visit and
by the way the more you have these
normalizations think about what that
will do to the economy of the West Bank
where they'll have you know great hotels
Hospitality uh tremendous tourism
industry because of all the Christian
Muslim uh and Jewish holy sites that
they have there so there's a lot of
potential there we just have to like get
unstuck I believe that it's so possible
if the leaders want to make tomorrow
better that they can and unfortunately
the people who suffer the most are
really are just the Palestinian people
and I think that you know in Gaza they
hostages to uh to Hamas and and in the
West Bank they're just they're just held
back because their leadership just is
afraid or or too
self-interested to give them the
opportunity to change their Paradigm and
pursue the potential of what they have
and by the way it's an incredibly
well-educated
population um it's it's an incredibly
capable population and they're right
next to Israel where the economy they
need everything and so the potential
should be incredible if you can just
move some of these pieces but again
there's still a lot of emotion and
hatred you have to work through as well
but I do believe that you're not going
to solve that by litigating the past
you're only going to solve that by
creating an exciting paradigm for the
future and getting everyone to buy in
and then move towards that and maybe
increase the chance of uh being able to
establish an economy where the
entrepreneurs can flourish in the West
Bank and so on in Palestine uh
once the uh the relationship across the
Arab world is normalized so so one thing
on that which is very interesting is
when I got into my job in in in in the
Middle East all the conventional
thinkers said to me the separation in
the Muslim world is between the S sunnis
and the Shia and that's really the big
divide and as I was traveling I didn't
think there was any divide in that
regard the divide that I saw was between
leaders who wanted to give a better
opportunity for their people and create
economic reforms and opportunity and
leaders who wanted to use religion or
fear to keep their stronghold on Power
and so if you think about who's not
creating the opportunity for their
people is the Palestinian leadership and
the Iranian leadership all the other
Arab countries were focused on how do we
give opportunity for our people to live
a better
life